Philadelphia, city of the Liberty Bell and sizzling cheese steaks,...
...where Rocky Balboa famously ran up the steps of the Museum of Art...
...exactly 40 years ago.
The USA wouldn't be the USA without its original capital city.
Philadelphia is the first American city to be designated as a World Heritage City,...
...joining the ranks of places like Paris, Kyoto and Jerusalem.
Start a visit at Independence Hall,...
...the place where American Independence and the constitution were first debated.
Drop by the Benjamin Franklin Museum...
...to hear stories of the local hero known as "The First American,"...
...and wander into a bar among the stately streets of the Old City...
...then sip a Yuengling,...
...a beer from America's oldest brewery.
But the city of brotherly love isn't a place content to trade on past glories.
NYC's more neighborly neighbor is experiencing a transformation...
...to its urban core.
Neighborhoods like Fishtown and East Passyunk...
...are being reinvigorated by a new wave of Philadelphians,...
...bringing with them a swath of new shops and restaurants,...
...including a high-concept Scandinavian kitchen, myriad pizza joints,...
...and Indonesian eateries all challenging the reign of the cheese steak.